when Brazil's Environment Minister stood
up to speak on the first day of his
country's climate week the reaction said
it all they don't believe the government
here is serious about protecting the
environment and the evidence they say is
there for all to see the tens of
thousands of wildfires now burning
through the Amazon more than ever before
and spreading at an alarming rate these
fires are often started by ranchers to
clear the forest and campaigners say
more deforestation is encouraged by the
country's president day-after Jaya balsa
Naro
appeared to blame environmental groups
for starting the fires he denied saying
it and claimed he was powerless nobody
writes I'll set fire to that if it
doesn't exist if you don't catch someone
red-handed while setting the fire then
look for those responsible for ordering
it it's a crime even more the Ministry
of Justice can send 40 men to combat the
fight but did you understand that 40 men
there are not enough resources we're in
chaos but as the Amazon burns there are
many who believe this is the result of a
lack of political will and don't hide
that they think the politicians are
lying we are not seeing concrete actions
it is just talking and no action the
scientists are already speaking about
the urgency of climate change the
importance to contain the emissions of
greenhouse gases co2 methane and to stop
the burning and deforestation of our
forests if you want to have a healthy
and clean future future generations in
Brazil's major cities the fires have
turned day to night but
environmentalists say the impact goes
way beyond this country alone losing the
Amazon would make the world's climate
targets impossible to meet they say this
is an emergency on a planetary scale as
if to prove the point the smoke is
visible from 400 miles up in space and
seeing the pictures in the middle of the
Atlantic the climate activists Greta Tim
Berg tweeted her reaction our war
against nature must end
she wrote there is a tension between
those who make their living from the
Amazon
and those who fear its nearing a tipping
point and a chain reaction that would
have consequences for us all
Greg Milam Sky News